[Music]
yep i'm stupid
they say it goes down in the dms but not
necessarily for t-pain
that blew my mind i had no idea on
thursday the rapper posted a video on
tick-tock
revealing he's been accidentally
ignoring a plethora of dms on instagram
for years
it was not a great feeling the video
shows t-pain looking disappointed
scrolling through countless messages
realizing that instagram has a separate
area for message requests
he also apologized in the caption
writing i swear
i'm just now seeing all these messages
and mentions today
how do i super apologize press
conference town hall meeting
i'm dumb as for the celebs who slid in
his dms it looks like viola davis
diplo and even fergie all tried to get t
payne to come to the phone
are you kidding me these are just the
ones i haven't
checked and replied to
yup i'm stupid t-pain
also posted the video on instagram where
many of his celeb pals
flooded the comments like ashanti who
admitted she did
the same exact thing two days ago
luckily t-pain isn't the first celeb
that's had a social media mishap oh my
god
earlier this month lizzo recently
revealed on tick tock that she drunkenly
slid into chris evans dms
the reason i'm upset about this one is
because
i know i'm not going to be able to marry
him and honestly it hurts me to the core
because damn papa he a rare breed no
comparing but lucky for lizzo
the singer ended up successfully
shooting her shot after sharing an
update on what happened between her and
chris
and it turns out he replied to her
saying quote god knows i've done worse
on this app and admitted that he's a fan
in 2019 lizzo told et why she thinks
it's easy to connect with other celebs
i definitely feel like um
i understand more and more why
famous people be because it's it's such
an interesting
world and i think it is hard to
understand what it's like to
have a connection with somebody outside
of all of this these people and famous
people
connect with millions of people at a
time and everybody
is in love with them and everybody wants
you everybody want to smash
everybody want to be your best friend so
it's like really hard to kind of
siphon through like and find the real
people but i mean even famous people can
be
so i don't know i might just have to
marry myself again